As anybody who's gone through adolescence knows, the body undergoes great
changes during that time. In fact, during puberty our bodies and brains change
more than at any other time in development except for early childhood. Puberty
is the onset of sexual maturity. We experience a growth spurt. Both sexes begin
to grow hair around their genitals and underarms. And men will begin to grow
facial hair. Women also start to develop breasts, and begin menstruating. The
technical term for the onset of menstruation is menart. Whereas the term for
the development of sperm through ejaculation is termed sperm mark. The
pituatary gland is critcial in the onset of puberty because it release hormones
including our sex hormones. For women the main sex hormone is estrogen where as
for men it's testosterone. It's important to note that both men and women have
estrogen and testosterone but women have more estrogen and men have more
testosterone. As we'll see when we get to the section on motivation, our sex
drive, both men and women's, is largely a function of testosterone. Now let's
go back to Lauren, and see the last part of our psychological domain in
adolescence.